oh damn
the king goes to g g one only move rook
a2
well maybe rook yeah still there's no
checks no he's unfortunately queen d1 or
something oh dear queen f4 much better
move but this will not be possible to
win
gosh
it's like magnus is just managing to
ride his luck it's unbelievable yeah
unfortunately for white he's not going
to be able to do anything apart from
making it draw
well okay there's still 15. but he
played so fast he still has four minutes
you know
yeah we will have to show you that's
that critical moment because
it was a fantastic game i just when he
played bishop f3 i just wanted to say
that white has to be careful with bishop
f3 because i was thinking i will show
you
okay i mean there's still some chances
whilst uh
well there is no chance to win this game
for white for black yes there it goes
so magnus carlsen
draws the game
and this means that because it was an
armageddon match
magnus will take home the one and a half
points and richard rapport and we can
say again that none of the players are
so satisfied with their performance but
we should show the critical moment right
because
it looked like everything was going
really things are awful for black at
this point